欢迎你学习白泽国际站运营实战系统课
同学们 这一小节我们来讲一下关于出口通和金品店铺的一些差别以及它的应用技巧
出口通是跟金品是不同的店铺类型
它只是在流量分配起始的权益上不一样
以及某些店铺后台的功能和前端展示的板块不一样而已
其他的获取流量以及直动车这些板块都是一样的
都是需要你去精细化的运营才有结果的
并不是说你出口通把它变成了新品店铺
流量就会大增
这是一种错误的认知
流量的大小不是和店铺类型转变直接挂钩的
而是根据你的操作能力来决定的
因为店铺的类型不代表流量的大小
流量一样是需要我们去竞争的
出口通的流量不一定就不如新品店铺
很多人的出口通的流量
可能比很多人的精品店铺效果还要好
所以一定要区分起来
这样的话你就会知道
你的店铺要不要升级为精品
你的精品店铺又该如何去做
这些思路清晰了
那么你去做事就有方向了
就知道具体做哪些事情了
那么精品店铺的话
它会有一个很大的一个价值
就在于有很多证书
或者是认证报告
这样会给客户更强的信任感
能够更加快的促进订单的转化
因为它有很多服务啊
还有很多证书啊
客户都能够直接看得到
而出口通就没有这项报告的认证
另外呢也没有那么多专属的权益
所以呢
这个就是他们的差异
如果你是精品店铺
一定要把精品所要呈现的价值
凸显出来
这样的话你的效果会更好
这个就是关于出口通和精品店铺的一个差别使用方法